on a ferris gives us some serious
fitness goals
it's totally surreal the 40 year old
actress is currently filming the
overboard remake in Canada and she looks
better than ever
on Wednesday Ferris was photographed on
set rocking a sexy yellow string bikini
check out those rock-hard abs and
seriously toned arms Farrah sinner
overboard co-star Eva Longoria have
taken to social media with several
behind-the-scenes moments from filming
here they are goofing around
Longoria captioned the pic I decided to
post this awesome photo of Anna checking
out my butt the co-star shared this
bootylicious moment while aboard a boat
on a even showed support for her
hometown team let's hope she didn't
actually go overboard in the process the
film is a remake of the 1987 rom-com
starring Goldie Hawn and Kurt Russell et
caught up with Ferris and April to find
out if we can expect any cameos in the
update there's any chance of code or
Goldie making an appearance man I was
from like your mouth I don't know yeah
we love that
[Music]